All right, with our UI now showing both our time and our score and our pickup working,
what we need to do now is make some menus for what happens when the game ends, as well
as a new level and a new menu for when you actually open the project.
So when I start, what do we want to have happen?
And this way we'll have a full game loop.
So the first thing we're going to do is we're going to create a brand new widget
blueprint and we're going to add a canvas panel to it like we did before.
But this time we're going to add an image to it, make that image expand across the
entire canvas panel so that we can add a game over screen like this.
So let's go ahead and pop over to the editor now and we're going to hit control
space and then right here in our content, we're just going to make a new user interface
widget blueprint based on a user widget and I call it a user widget underscore game
over.
All right.
So let's double click on this to open it up.
And first things first, we do need to add a canvas panel.
So we're going to look for CANV and we're going to look for that canvas panel right
there.
So we're going to drag that right over our UW game over.
Okay.
The next thing we're going to look for is a image right there.
So there's the image.
We're going to bring that down now with our image.
Let's do a couple of things.
So we're going to go to our anchors here, we're going to hit control and we're going
to select this one right here.
And the reason we're going to do that, remember, that's going to allow this thing
to be as big as we need it to be for any UI size.
The other thing we're going to do is we're going to come over here to the color and
opacity and change this maybe to like some bluish color, something like that.
And we need to add a few elements to our canvas over here.
So what we're going to add is we're going to add some text first.
And then with our text here, we're going to again size this to content.
And this first text is going to say game over.
And then we're going to set it something like 64.
And a couple of things we're going to do here, we're going to take this anchor
and we're going to put it by holding control and we're going to go right here in the
middle, but we're going to take our alignment and set this to point five.
And this is going to move our box over and this is just going to make it a lot
easier for us to position this up, not on the X position, but on the Y position.
So, again, all I did is I just took that alignment, put it to point five, and
then this just makes things a little bit easier to get it kind of centered on the
page there. I'm also going to put an outline of maybe like three on this and
maybe do the size to like ninety six.
There we go. So game over.
And then what we'll do is we will click on this and we will just duplicate it and
then we will move this up just a little bit more.
Not the size. I'm sorry.
We want to grab that game over and we want the Y position here.
So we just move this up and then we will make this say final score and then
we'll actually do a little space right there.
All right. And then the last thing that we're going to do is we're going to add a
button here. So we'll take this button and bring it right down onto the canvas
panel, make sure it's selected.
And then like we did before with our anchors, we're going to come here.
We're going to hold down control and click.
So that's anchored down here at the bottom of our screen, much like I did
with the text. I'm going to take the alignment set to point five.
And then this just makes it easier to position this up on the middle right
here. The other thing we're going to do is we're going to take some text
here and we're going to drag it right onto the button.
And that's going to nest the text in that button.
And if we click on with the button selected size to content, we can
then have our text here, say something like restart.
And then we'll increase this maybe like sixty four.
There we go. And give it an outline to.
So there we go. We have our game over our final score and then our
restart button, just like we have right here.
And what we're going to do next is we are going to bind some text to our
final score so that we can have that update when the game is over.
So when the game is over, we'll show this menu screen.
So like we did before, we're going to do the final score.
We're going to create a binding.
We're going to go to the player pawn.
We're going to get cast to our BP sports car.
We're going to get the current score and we're going to use that as the
value with our format text for final score and then the value.
So let's pop back over here to our editor and then our final score.
So that's what we want.
We want to come over to our content text, click on that binding,
create binding, and then we're going to get player pawn.
And it would help if I would spell that correctly.
There we go. Get player pawn.
And then from our player pawn, we are going to cast to BP and we
want this cast to BP sports car.
Remember, we're going to convert this to a pure cast because we
know the value that we are getting.
And we're, we're a hundred percent sure that current get
current score is there.
Okay.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to format text.
And what are we going to do with this?
Well, we're going to say final score and then make a space, two
curly brackets and the word value.
And this is going to allow us to move this over and then go like this.
So let's compile and save this.
So again, we're going from our player pawn, we're casting to our
BP sports car to get the current score, and then we're using our
format text, putting in our final score, remember double curly brackets
for the value so that we can get that current score and
display that as the final value.
Next, what we're going to do is we're going to select the button
that we put restart on.
And when we do an on clicked event, that's going to give us an on
click and we're going to use this to basically open up the level
that we were in again, by creating this little bit of blueprint code.
So let's come over to our editor.
So we're going to go back to the designer and then we're going to
make sure that we have our button selected and that all the way down
to the bottom of the details panel, we have our on clicked events.
So on clicked, there we go.
So we're going to get player controller.
All right.
And then we are going to, uh, set and put mode game only.
And then we're going to open level by name, and we need to give
this a level name of L V L underscore B E H I C L E B A S B A S I C
vehicle basic, which is, uh, this level right here.
All right.
So let's make sure we compile and save.
We can close this down.
And now what we need to do is we're going to open up our game mode.
And remember our countdown uses a branch so that we can do something
on the true and something on the false.
So what we're going to be doing is we are going to be
doing something on the, uh, true.
So when the value equals zero, what are we going to do?
Well, we are going to remove our current UI.
Then we're going to show the mouse cursor.
We're going to set the input mode to UI only.
So the player can only interact with the UI.
We're going to create our game over widget that we just built, and then
we're going to add that to the viewport.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So remember we need to come over to our, uh, blueprints, BP GM
vehicle, basic game mode.
And remember, we're going to do this on the true.
So we are going to say, remove from, and we want to remove from,
remove from parent, there we go.
And we're going to take this right here.
So we want to remove the current UI.
And then what we're going to do is we're going to go set show mouse cursor to true.
Okay.
So we're going to set our current mouse cursor to true.
And then we are going to set input mode to a UI only.
All right.
And we also need to get player controller.
I'm going to put on my context sensitivity so that I can get to our game
player controller, uh, because we need to tell what player controller we
currently want to enable all of this stuff on so for our set show mouse
cursor, the target is going to be our current player controller as
well as our set input mode UI only.
Then what we're going to do is we are going to create, uh, create widget.
And what widget do we want to create?
What we want to create our game over and who do we want to create that widget for?
Well, we want to create it for our current player controller, and then we
need to add to viewport and to be, there we go, add to viewport this widget.
So if we compile and save this, now, what should happen when I press play
and the time gets to zero?
Well, let me just get a little bit of time here and it counts down to zero.
What should happen is we should now see our menu pop up.
And once we do that, once we verify that we will move on to the next part, which is
going to be creating our empty level for our main menu.
So let's press restart and boom, there we go.
We have restarted.
All right.
So perfect.
What we're going to do now is make a new empty level called main menu.
And we're then going to go to our project settings and our maps and modes and make
sure that our editor startup map and our game default map are set to the start menu.
This way that when we start our game, it's always going to load that map.
We could leave the editor startup map to the default.
But in this case, we don't we can choose to do that either way, which is great.
So we're going to do a file new level.
I want to say empty.
All right.
And we're going to save stuff because we've made some changes and then we're going to
hit control s and I'm just going to save this in my content and we're going to call
it main menu, main menu.
There we go.
All right.
And then we're going to go up to our edit project settings.
I'm going to bring the project settings on screen for you to see here.
We're going to go down to our maps and modes, and I'm just going to make sure
that the game default map is this main menu map that I made.
So just change that to main menu.
All right.
Then what we're going to be doing is we're going to create another widget
blueprint.
And with this widget blueprint, what we're going to do is we're going to make a
background, some text and a button.
And when we press that button, we're going to make sure we show our mouse cursor and
then we are going to set the input mode game only.
And then we're going to open our level.
And this works pretty much like we did with the other project.
So let's go ahead and come over here to the editor window.
So again, we're going to close this down.
OK, I'm going to hit control space and then we're going to come up to our content.
Right click a user interface widget blueprint based off of a user widget.
I'm going to call it a user widget underscore main menu.
All right.
And let's double click on this to open it up.
So again, we need our canvas canvas panel.
We're going to drag that down.
And then we also need an image.
Remember, with the image, we're going to hold down control and select the anchor that is
right here on the very, very bottom right to spread that all the way across the
screen. Give it some color, maybe something like that.
And then we're going to add some text.
So remember, with our text, we're going to select it.
We will say size to content.
We can hit control or click on the anchors.
I'm sorry. Press control.
Bring that to the center and set its offset here by point five, just to make it easier to
align it to the center.
I'm going to say ninety six for the text and we'll just call this car game.
Very, very great title there.
Spent a lot of time thinking about it.
We'll just move it down a little bit and then we need to add a button.
So we're going to add a button.
There we go. And again, with our button, we're going to come to our anchors.
We're going to hit control to bring it down there and then we're going to offset it by
point five and then we'll just bring this up on the Y axis somewhere.
There we go. Like negative four hundred.
There we go. Then we're going to put some text inside of it like so.
There we go. And we'll size that and then we will make that text also say start
game and we will also give it like some outline and go.
Let's also give this guy a little bit of an outline here.
We go car game.
All right. And then what we want to do is with our button here, we want to on click.
OK, and we want to we want to set show mouse cursor to true.
And then we're going to do that for our turn on contact sensitivity again, because
it's just cuts down on the clutter.
Get player controller.
There we go. And then we are going to set and put mode to game only.
And then what we're going to do is we are going to open level by name.
And what's the level we're going to open?
Well, it is LVL underscore, V E H I C L E A S C.
All right. So let's just compile and save and recap.
So again, off of our unclicked, we're going to show our mouse cursor to true.
We're going to set our input mode to the player controller.
We're going to open the level by name.
That's what happens when we do that start game.
So here is the blueprint for that.
What we're going to do now is we are going to open our level blueprint so that when we
start, we can actually show this mouse cursor and load this UI.
And we're also going to change our game mode to game mode override.
If we leave it at the current game mode, what is going to happen is the car will
actually spawn and then we will lose our UI.
So let's go ahead and set all of this up right now.
So we're going to come here.
I can close this for the time being, but we are going to come up to our open level
blueprint and then we can get rid of the event tech because we don't need to do
something every frame. We just want to do it on a fit begin play.
So we're going to go create widget and the widget we want to create is our main
menu. And then we're going to add to viewport like so.
OK, then what we're going to do is we're going to go set show mouse and I'm going to
disable context sensitivity to find this.
We want to set that mouse cursor to true so that the user can actually use their
mouse. They're going to go get player controller and I'm going to enable my
context sensitivity because I want this game get player controller and we're going to
plug that in to the return value here on our target.
And then we are going to set input mode UI only and we are going to put the player
controller into there as well.
And this is going to just allow us to make sure that we're only controlling the
UI. The other thing I'm going to do after I close this is come here to our world
settings and then my game mode override.
I'm just going to change this to game mode.
So what should happen now is when I press play, I will start the game.
Go, let me just get some time and a score here, so we'll wait for just a few few
moments for this to count its way down.
Probably should have picked a shorter time.
It's crazy how long 10 seconds seems to be when you're doing a demo versus when you
are testing. So there we go.
The time should be over and we should be able to restart.
And there we go. There we have it.
So again, we start our game, we can start the game, and then the time will run out
and we can restart. We have something like this.
So one of the other things that you could do to extend this further is on the restart
here, you could actually add a quit or a main menu option.
So you could have a look for the option quit inside of the editor.
There's an option there that will quit your project for you.
You can add that as a bonus.
And then you could also restructure the restart code to have something that takes
you to the main menu level so that you can then further refine your project's
game loop.